[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMIR ROUZROKH: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for coming to Power of
Java Workloads and Google Cloud
Platform session.
Sorry for the half an hour delay
compared to the original time.
But thank you for being here.
I think you're going
to enjoy it a lot.
So let's just start
off with introductions.
My name is Amir Rouzrokh.
I am a product
manager in Gogle Cloud
Platform responsible
for Java and Python
developer experience.
And this is Patrick.
PATRICK FLYNN: Hi everybody.
I'm Patrick Flynn.
I'm the tech lead of the
Java tools team on GCP.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Great.
OK.
So we have a lot of
demos today for you guys.
So I'm going to go through this
a little bit faster so we make
sure we get you guys all the
demos that we're hoping for you
to see.
So let me just quickly
talk about what
we're going to touch on today.
We are going to use
the IntelliJ IDE.
And just for me to understand
sort of the breakdown,
how many of you guys use
IntelliJ to work with Java?
OK.
Wow.
All right.
That's pretty harsh.
And how many Eclipse users?
OK So I'd say about
like a 70, 30-ish.
OK.
All right.
And I know there's other IDEs,
and also other board editors.
But OK.
That's good to know.
We're going to use a Spring
Boot application, Java8 based.
That's what we're
going to deploy.
We are going to touch
on two of our platforms.
And I'm going to talk about
our entire platform offering.
But the ones that we're
going to talk about today,
we're going to show
demos on, is going
to be App Engine flexible
environment, and Container
Engine, which runs
on Kubernetes.
It's based on Kubernetes,
is probably more accurate.
We're going to look at
tools for services, logging
and Cloud Debugger.
And we're going to do
some infrastructure
demos around AB testing, load
balancing, and auto-scaling.
But I think it's going to
be pretty interesting stuff
that you're going to see.
But before we go there I'm
just going to talk about some
of the pain points
that I think all of us
deal with on a daily basis.
And we went and talked
with a lot of our customers
a couple of years ago,
and started really
understanding what are the daily
issues that they deal with?
And the common thread
was, obviously,
they'd be like, great developers
and engineers that they have.
But a lot of their
time was being spent
on non-core business workflows.
Doing things that are just
not core to the business
that they run.
You know, first thing is
a lot of the developers
are pretty comfortable
when they're in their IDE,
and they know their code
is right over there,
and everything that they handle.
But then when they
need to do something
with the infrastructure they
have to leave that environment,
and start working
with some Web UI,
are some CLI, or
something like that.
The A/B test thing and traffic
splitting was a big problem.
People, you know, get
a version up and ready.
And they want to
put it out there
to see if it's actually
enhancing the product, if it's
not breaking.
Maybe they want to do some
tests before rolling it
fully out into
production and they
needed to get networking
involved for that.
And that was a lot of hassle.
Let's say that's all set up.
Now they want to make
sure that the scaling
of this infrastructure
is taken care of,
and it's load balanced
across all the instances.
A lot of work there.
There may be spikes in the
morning when people wake up.
And then later when they go
home things just fall down.
And they wanted to not
have to worry about that.
Security, another issue.
Patches come out.
Every once in a
while, you know, there
is a vulnerability somewhere.
They have to go
back, patch that.
Running, sort of, application
production now is tedious.
And there's always
logs, of course.
You have to figure out
where you write them.
Are you going to
rotate these logs?
And that's all, sort of,
non-core to the business.
And what we heard a
lot about, and we're
going to talk about
this more today is
a lot of the
developers, there would
be bugs that appear
in production,
and then they wanted to get
this bug to happen in QA,
or nightly, or test, or
on their local machine,
and they just couldn't
replicate that bug
that was live on their
local machine to debug this.
I'm curious, have you
guys bumped into this
before where you had if--
people are laughing.
But if you could raise
your hands just for a no.
OK.
All right.
So there we go.
So yeah, so that
happens quite often.
It's a big waste of time.
And last but not
least, people want
to have this vendor flexibility.
So if they've decided to go with
a cloud provider or a platform
they want to be able to,
if they want to change
their mind later,
they don't want
to have to go back and
redo the whole thing.
They want to just be able to
switch between the layers.
So we're going to
talk about that
and show that in the
demo today as well.
So we saw these pain
points and we decided, OK,
it's good to put a product
together that really
talks to all of these.
And today we're going
to talk about App Engine
Flexible environment as
the first part of our demo.
And what is App Engine
Flexible environment?
It is a fully managed
application platform
that basically allows
developers to build web apps,
and API services.
OK.
This is a really
long description.
Really what we're saying,
you just bring your code
and we'll handle the rest.
You just focus on your
business specific code
and forget about
all the other stuff,
pain points that we showed.
And in the demo today what
we're going to look at
is I'm going to try to
do a description of what
our compute offering looks like.
So if you look at the bottom,
that's Google's infrastructure,
that's opaque to you
guys, but the first layer
is the virtual machines, right?
Super high control.
You get your VMs
and you can really
do whatever you want with them.
So that's GCE.
Nice logo over there.
And then if you think about
what's the next level, that's
containers, right?
And if you want to have
Kubernetes and container
management on top of
that, that gives you
a bit more control over where
the workflows are managed.
You know, you're not just
working with these pure VMs.
They have a lot of flexibility.
Still, there is work to be
done in setting things up.
Then on top of that we kind
of enter the serverless space
where you're just
not really thinking
about the infrastructure all.
App Engine being the, sort of
like, more flexible version
of it, both Standard
and Flexible.
And we'll talk about that.
And then Cloud functions,
which there are also
sessions about that if
you guys want to join.
But what we're going to
really think about here
is this space over here.
We're going to
start from the top.
And then we're
going to move down.
That kind of shows
you how you can
go between the
layers, when you're
working with your application.
So all right what does App
Engine give you out of the box?
A lot of things.
I'm just going to
highlight six of them here.
Logging comes out of the box.
Nothing to worry about.
We'll demo that.
Auto scaling and load balancing
pre-configured for you.
Monitoring is there.
So if things break and
you want to be notified.
Health checks.
Something is not
working, an instance
has gone on healthy
for some reason.
It's not working.
You want to be notified.
And then SSL and domains.
So just to make
sure we're on time,
let me just about some
of the environments, some
of the languages
that it supports.
We're going to
work on Java today.
But if you have any one
of the other languages
here you can deploy to
that environment as well.
You know, JS, Ruby, Java,
Go, Python, .Net, PHP,
you've got them all.
As a matter of fact, you can use
any Docker container as well.
And that's sort of
what's happening
at the layer behind it.
That's what's happening
behind the scenes.
So you know, and we'll
show you that, you guys,
but you can go any
other language as well,
but these are
pre-configured for you.
And we found that this
covers most of the languages
that people use.
So today's demo, we're going to
use Google provider run times.
They get security patched
on a weekly basis.
So we don't worry about that.
On App Engine
inflexible you don't
need any configuration files.
You guys have probably seen
all these massive configuration
files you know, that you
have to kind of understand
which every line is.
No need for that.
It's optional if you want
to configure anything.
But no need for it.
You can customize the
number of cores, memory,
and disk per instance.
And by customizing
that I mean, let's
say you have a workload
that's very CPU intensive.
Let's say it processes video.
But it maybe doesn't
need much memory.
So you can go and have
a 32 or 16 core instance
with a very small
amount of memory,
and exactly to the
number that you want.
So they are customizable
to number of cores,
and to the exact
megabyte of the memory.
And same goes for disks.
So that really gets
you a lot of saving.
You don't need to buy
these massive instances
and be wasteful of memory,
or disks, or cores.
Everything's load balanced
and autoscaled from ground up.
And AB testing, which
we're going to show.
Container and Microservices
is ready natively.
And we'll show that in a second.
And the vendor
flexibility is there.
And I'll show that it's not
Google specific, actually,
two other cloud
providers as well.
So without further
ado, Patrick, why
don't you go through all
this and give us a demo.
PATRICK FLYNN: OK.
Let's get started.
I was happy to see a lot
of you are IntelliJ users.
This is going to be
especially relevant for you.
We're using IntelliJ
for the demos today.
My team builds a
number of plug-ins
into both Eclipse,
IntelliJ, and Maven, Gradle.
And we target all kinds of
Google Cloud platform services.
We're going to focus on App
Engine today, and the Google
Cloud Debugger.
So the first thing that you'll
see here is that we're--
actually, sorry to
ask so many questions,
but show of hands, how many of
you use the Spring framework?
That's what I thought.
You'd have to be hiding in
a cave the last 10 years
or 15 years not to know
about the Spring framework.
It's really important for
us that it's really easy
to take a typical Spring boot
application, deploy it to GCP,
and things will just
work as you expect,
or even better than you expect.
So what you see here is
basically a at rest controller.
I just downloaded the
Spring Boot demo from GitHub
and modified it to add some
endpoints for this demo.
It's really just plain
vanilla Spring boot.
So what we can do is we have
all of our tools, features
bundled together in
this sub-menu over here.
And also in the natural
entry points where
they should be in the IDE.
We have Google Cloud source
repository integration,
which lets you check in and
import into the free google
Cloud Source repositories
we offer in your project.
We
Have Cloud, AKA Stackdriver
debugger integration,
which we'll talk about later.
And we also have App
Engine support for you.
So you can run your
local dev app server
for App Engine standard.
You can deploy both the App
Engine standard and App Engine
Flex.
For local run for
Flex, obviously it's
sort of your own environment.
So we let you figure
that out for yourself.
AMIR ROUZROKH:
Actually, can describe,
how do we get this plugin to,
you know, appear on IntelliJ?
PATRICK FLYNN: Oh yeah, sure.
Most of you will probably
know, as you're IntelliJ users,
that JetBrains has a plug-in
repository that you can access
through preferences, or
settings, in another operating
system.
You just go to
Browse Repositories.
Search for Google Cloud.
And you'll see our
tool right there.
Install, Restart, and
you're good to go.
So what I'm going
to do first is we're
going to take our
application and deploy it
to App Engine Flex.
So this is our deploy UI.
The first, probably,
most important thing
that you need to decide when
you're deploying to App Engine
Flex is, what are you
deploying to App Engine Flex.
There is a peculiarity
about IntelliJ--
this is ultimate
edition by the way--
where if you're
building a web project
it will automatically create
a web artifact for you
that people often
use for deployment.
But it does not do
that for jar based
projects, which typical
Spring boot projects are.
What we've done is we actually
inspect your Maven model
and figure out what
your primary target is
and allow you to deploy that.
So what you see here is the
option of basically selecting
that Maven build for
this project, which
is called Spring Boot Simple.
You can also just pick
a file system jar/war
anywhere in your file system,
and we'll package that,
and deploy it for you.
Next thing you
need to do is pick
which GCP project you want
to deploy your project to.
So it's a real
pain in the butt--
[LAUGHING]
yeah, sorry there--
to actually have
to configure authentication
for tools typically, right?
You have to either create a
service account or application
default credentials all
on your cloud provider
and put that in a
key file somewhere.
We take all that pain away
by having this login widget,
which, if I hit Add
Account will take you
through a web flow
for authentication,
and store the
credentials locally.
So your session is
just there for as long
as you want it to be.
I'm going to cancel this
because I've done this already.
So we have this user.
This is my personal
account, by the way.
And I'm going to pick the
project I want to deploy to.
Because this project has already
been enabled for App Engine
you can see which region
it's deploying to.
And then we see
that the environment
is App Engine Flexible,
because we also
support Engine standard.
If your app had App
Engine Web XML then
you would see App
Engine standard here.
And finally, we have
the version field,
which I'm going to
overwrite in this case
to 5.8, which I think is
the version of the code
that I've got checked out.
AMIR ROUZROKH: So Patrick--
PATRICK FLYNN: Sure.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Just to like--
I mean, so this is, I have
a version already installed.
I can just, basically over here,
version up right from the IDE,
and deploy the next
versions going forward.
So my, let's say, current
production is 5.7.
Something like that?
PATRICK FLYNN: Sure.
Absolutely.
We're going to talk a little
bit more about versioning
and the App Engine model
for services and versions
in a second.
AMIR ROUZROKH: OK.
PATRICK FLYNN: So I'm going
to kick off this deployment.
So what we'll do
is we'll make sure
that your Maven
artifact has been built,
which takes just obviously
a few seconds, hopefully.
And then we actually
package source context
into it, which we'll also
talk about when we show you
the Cloud Debugger.
And start the
deployment process.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Patrick,
so in the background,
you know what [INAUDIBLE]
says building and pushing
image for service service,
or this micro servers,
and this is a container
based sort of deployment,
but you really didn't
have to deal with Docker,
Docker Push Image Hub, like
you know, all that stuff.
PATRICK FLYNN: That's right.
AMIR ROUZROKH: You just went
from code to containers.
How did that happen?
PATRICK FLYNN: The sort of
vision for App Engine Flexible
is to have standard
infrastructure for running
containers.
But what they want to
do is make it as easy
as possible for people to use
a platform without knowing
anything about containers.
So if you don't
want to customize
your image with some native
dependency you don't have to.
You don't need to have a Docker
or file, or even app gammel.
And you don't even need to
have Docker installed locally,
because we have a Cloud build
service, which will orchestrate
into the deployment so that we
can produce the right Docker
artifact for you.
AMIR ROUZROKH: I see.
PATRICK FLYNN: So that's
what's happening right now.
We're actually streaming
the results of the Cloud
build for the Docker build
back into the console.
But it's actually all happening
on the Cloud at the moment.
AMIR ROUZROKH: So you
built a container,
you're pushed into through
a repository, the Google
Container Repository, and
you made it to go live,
and you hooked up all the
networking, and all of that.
OK.
PATRICK FLYNN: Yeah.
So because this is not
App Engine standard
and because it's sort of
built on the basic building
blocks of virtual machines
you see the products
that you're most familiar with
at the base of the pyramid
we looked at earlier.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Right.
PATRICK FLYNN: The cost
of spinning everything up
is a little larger
than for App Engine
standard which uses shared
resources for deployments.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Correct.
PATRICK FLYNN: So it's
updating the service here.
I'm going to go over
to the Cloud Console
and show you the
App Engine console.
This is actually
some deployments
that I did earlier
just so that we
didn't have to wait too long for
the new version to be serving.
What you can see
here is that we've
got version 5.8 serving,
and version 5.7 serving,
version 5.6 serving.
The traffic allocation's
100% on 5.7.
This is basically your
version that all your users
are currently seeing.
We've done a deployment to
5.8 that nobody is currently
seeing.
So App Engine
provides a model that
helps you with a
microservices architecture
through our services so
that you could basically
label your deployments
with a specific service.
And if you go into your
services list over here
you'll see all your
services and versions.
AMIR ROUZROKH: So you have
one service right now,
and one version.
Now, what I usually
do is I don't
want to send all the
traffic to the new one,
because things may be breaking.
Can we do 5% of traffic, maybe?
PATRICK FLYNN: Yeah, absolutely.
When I worked in the olden
days on Java Backend,
trying to set up either
experimentation features, or AB
testing, or just
release verification
was so difficult we
didn't even bother, right?
AMIR ROUZROKH: Right.
PATRICK FLYNN: We would
just deploy and roll out.
And if there was a
bug rollback, right?
But now with App Engine Flex
and App Engine Standard,
it's really easy to just
change the traffic mix
so that a really small
proportion of your users
start seeing the new code.
So we're going to save that.
And in a matter of seconds
the App Engine front ends
will start sending some of your
traffic to your new version.
Let's see here.
Refresh the page.
There you go.
All right.
So you have 9% of your traffic
served by this new version.
AMIR ROUZROKH: And Patrick,
let's say this is broken.
Can we roll back, please?
PATRICK FLYNN: Yeah,
sure I'll roll it back.
We select that.
Click over here.
Migrate the traffic back.
I should also show you, this is
just a silly, hello world app.
But this is v5.7.
Now, let's say we've
verified that 5.8 is good,
and we want to send 100%
of the traffic to it.
We can do that.
Migrate the traffic.
Should be only a
couple of seconds.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Yeah.
It shouldn't take more
than just a few moments.
There we go.
PATRICK FLYNN: OK.
100% of our traffic is now
being served by the new version.
If I go back here I see that
5.8 is the version being
served to my end users.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Awesome.
All right.
So Patrick, you know,
let's say 5.8 was
a really successful release.
PATRICK FLYNN: Yeah.
AMIR ROUZROKH: And it's
getting really, really famous
and people are just
coming right to our app.
What do I do?
PATRICK FLYNN: That's
a good question.
This is another
thing that when you
were faced with this
issue in the past
it was a real headache.
You don't have enough capacity.
Either, your consumer app that's
been more successful than you
had hoped for, right?
AMIR ROUZROKH: Right.
PATRICK FLYNN: Or you're
getting really spiky traffic
where you need a
lot of resources
at a certain time of day, but
not at the rest of the day.
What you really wish
you could have is not
worry about capacity and have
capacity managed for you.
And App Engine
actually does that.
So what we'll do
is we'll show you
that we've got the versions.
Let's go to the instances and
take a quick look over here.
We see that there are currently
two instances running for--
yeah, that's version 5.8.
Good.
Refresh.
So by default, without
any configuration,
we'll run two instances
just for backup.
If there's an issue you
still couldn't serve traffic.
But what we'll do now is--
let me just actually
show you real quick.
You saw it earlier.
There's an endpoint
on this web app
that is very slow and very
computationally expensive.
So what we're going to do--
sometimes it comes back really
quick and sometimes it comes
back really slow, because
it's just calculating digests
of numbers and looking for one
that starts with 007 on a loop.
So it really taxes the CPU.
So what I'm going
to do now is I'm
going to use Apache Bench to
simulate 10,000 requests, 20
requests at a time.
I'm going to go
ahead and start that.
AMIR ROUZROKH: So
I guess, Patrick,
what I saw here, if you
didn't do any configurations
around capacity
provisioning, I didn't
see anywhere you telling us
this could or could not happen,
or what sort of version this is.
So how does the back end
know that this is going
to, you know, be an issue?
PATRICK FLYNN: That's
a good question.
I think by default
the CPU load is
what the autoscaler is
going to use as a signal
for spinning up extra instances.
But you have a lot
of control over that.
If you specify your
own app yaml you
can do it based off of
[INTERPOSING VOICES] PPS.
So all kinds of things.
AMIR ROUZROKH: OK.
That's awesome.
PATRICK FLYNN: So let's
go back and take a look
at our instances really quick.
So you can see now that App
Engine has already started
spinning up a new instance.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Sorry,
I'm going to make a note.
It says no requests
at this time is
because it takes a minute or
two for the request to propagate
into the dashboard.
PATRICK FLYNN: So there's a
little lag on the summary.
AMIR ROUZROKH:
This is a new demo.
But yeah, so you can see in the
bottom, the VM is starting up.
Maybe do another refresh.
PATRICK FLYNN: Yep.
So now this is really
taxing the system.
And to make sure that we
keep on serving traffic
in a reasonable latencies
where the system is continuing
to spin up instances,
and at some point
is going to find that it's
handling the traffic well
enough, and it's going to stop.
AMIR ROUZROKH:
All load balanced.
Can you do another refresh?
So I'm thinking the last--
we spun up from 2, 2, 6 to 7.
And two more coming up.
PATRICK FLYNN: Yeah, and OK.
Let's see.
Seven of them are
already serving.
So these instances get spun
up, and work a lot faster than,
for instance, a deployment.
It's not like
you're going to have
to wait many minutes before
you're serving the new traffic
with these instances.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Write that script
and get it back, and set up.
PATRICK FLYNN: It gives
you a lot of agility.
And when the traffic
stops App Engine will
scale down so that you're not
spending more than you need to.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Just
for my pleasure,
can you do another refresh?
PATRICK FLYNN: Sure.
Let's see where we're at.
Let's go all the way down.
AMIR ROUZROKH: All right.
I think it found--
all right, see it ought
to have scaled up to--
PATRICK FLYNN: That's
like 10 instances going?
OK.
All right.
I think that was it for
this part of the demo.
Should we go back to slides?
AMIR ROUZROKH: Yeah.
Slides please.
OK.
Cool.
So let me just take
a second to describe
what we did right now, right?
We started off with
a plain application.
We containerized
it without really
having to interact with Docker.
We employed a microservices
architecture in the background.
We have a repository that
has our container in it
for future reference.
The container went
online and went healthy,
with two instances.
We did a AB test to see if
the version of the service
is actually what we want.
We verified that it was.
Then we migrated
everything over.
Then we loaded the
microservice and it scaled up.
I mean, think
about how much time
it would take for you
to go through this cycle
if you would want to do this
through the traditional way
of handling an end to end
infrastructure for application
development?
This took about nine minutes,
I think, on my clock over here.
So this is pretty good.
And it's a lot of addition to
productivity for developers.
So developer time is now free
to work on what's critical,
and that's your business.
Not on the other stuff.
And so if we move back to
what I showed you guys.
And we were up here, right?
Now, the question may be, OK.
You know this is a
lot of good magic.
I really like it.
But I really want more control.
I want to actually have
my containers set up
in different regions.
I want to have these
containers to have
a certain level of redundancy.
You just really want to
have all the control.
All right, cool.
And sure, you made the
App Engine decision first
when you were getting in.
But now you can just drop
down to the container level
using our Google
Container Engine,
which is based on Kubernetes.
And there are a lot of
talks about Kubernetes.
And you guys should definitely--
I would recommend
going, and check it out.
But Kubernetes is a container
orchestration system.
And we have a hosted
version of Kubernetes
which is called Google
Container Engine.
And what we're going
to show you guys here
is we're going to get
this migration happening,
going from App Engine
to Container Engine.
So we're going to show that.
And then we're going to now work
with the live debugging issue
that we talked
about, and see what
happens if this application is
actually having the bug that we
can't replicate locally.
And logging as well,
which is a big problem.
So Patrick, let's drop down
one level on the infrastructure
layer, and get some
debugging, and logging going.
Back to the demo, please.
Thank you.
PATRICK FLYNN: OK.
This was a fun little project.
Basically, figure out how do
we replicate the experience we
just showed you on App
Engine on Kubernetes
with the same
service integration
that app engine offers.
For instance, the Cloud
Debugger, and Google Cloud
Logging, and Google Trace.
All those products should
just magically work.
With GKE you have your
own configuration.
You're sort of responsible
for making everything work.
That turned out most of
this is really easy to do.
And the reason that I--
basically I selected the
open JDK8 from Docker Hub
as my base image, which is
not the image I would normally
recommend.
I would recommend using our own
Google curated images, which
do a lot of extra work to make
sure the configurations are
right, and they're updated
for security patches
on a weekly basis.
But I just want to show that
with a plain vanilla image--
AMIR ROUZROKH:
Right, and I think
that's a good example of--
PATRICK FLYNN: and
minimal configuration you
can actually deploy the
same app on to Kubernetes,
and have integration to
the rest of our services.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Patrick,
I was going to say,
like, this is a
good example of you
know, you can just, go to a
different runtime, if you want.
There's nothing
holding you back.
So all right.
PATRICK FLYNN: Yeah.
So if you see here, all we're
doing is using the base image.
Exposing 8080, downloading
the Cloud Debugger Agent,
which is open source
on GitHub, by the way,
and configuring it in the agent
path of the Java invocation.
So this is what a typical Spring
boot Docker image would have.
Java and then the app.
But there's an extra step
that we have to do, because--
we're going to be talking
about the Cloud Debugger later,
but one thing that App Engine
offers that Raw Infrastructure
Environment does not is
the service inversion model
so that you can identify
a large set of instances
as providing the
same job, right?
Providing the same binary.
Doing the same thing.
We need to do that for our
diagnostics integration.
So what I've done here
is used Maven filtering
to actually filter
the service name
and project version
properties from the project
into the Docker file, OK?
And let me just quickly show
you the POM XML as well.
You guys are going get tired
of this, but how many of you
are using Maven regularly?
Yeah.
Gradle, out of curiosity?
OK.
It's more or less
what I expected.
AMIR ROUZROKH: So
it's like 70, 30?
PATRICK FLYNN: It's like 70, 30.
Something like that.
So we have Gradle
and Maven plug-ins.
So everybody is covered.
In Maven there are various
ways that you can build
Docker images from a Java app.
So we showed you earlier
that with App Engine Flex
you don't actually need
to worry about that part.
But if you're deploying
to Kubernetes.
We're no longer taking care
of the Docker build for you.
You need to create the image.
The way that I've done that is
I just took the Spotify Docker
Maven plug-in.
They have two of them.
They both work differently.
I just picked this one for
the purposes of this demo.
And the image name is
actually really important
because the Google Cloud
Platform offers a Docker image
Container Registry, called
the Google Container Registry.
AMIR ROUZROKH:
That's a good name.
PATRICK FLYNN: G star dot io.
Name your image after G star dot
io slash your project and then
your artifact name and any
tags you want to add to it.
So we do that here.
And then once you've built your
Docker image all you need to do
is push it to Container
Registry, which
is as easy as calling--
you should see here--
G Cloud Docker push
the name of your image.
I've got two layers of
zooming going on right now.
All right.
So I can show you--
what I've actually done
here is kind of neat.
I've bound exec-ing
the G Cloud Docker
push to the deploy phase
of my Maven project,
because if you think about
it, the Maven life cycles,
deploy is about
publishing your artifacts.
And your artifact, when your
Docker base is no longer a Java
artifact it's Doctor image.
So if I kick that
off what'll happen
is we will build the application
filter, the docker file.
Create a staging directory,
and Docker build that.
And then push that to
Google Container Registry.
AMIR ROUZROKH: So
Patrick, if I could have,
if I have another container
that I've built previously
on another platform,
or another place,
I could just point to that,
and deploy that on Kubernetes,
and GKE, right?
PATRICK FLYNN: Yeah,
with containers
there's a whole lot of
stuff that you could do.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Right.
PATRICK FLYNN: One thing that
we didn't mention earlier
is that App Engine Flex also
uses Google Container Registry.
So I'm going to
take you over there.
And you can take a look.
This is the Google Cloud Console
and the Container Registry
page.
You can actually see all
of our App Engine builds
show up in here.
So we can see the
previous deployments
that we did right there.
These images are
deployable to Kubernetes.
Now, if you take a
look at demo app,
which is the image that we
just pushed, we have v5.8,
which is actually the
image from 22 minutes ago.
I pushed an earlier example.
So this is the one
that you were seeing.
I didn't make any modifications.
All right.
So this service is actually
running on Kubernetes news
at the moment.
If we go to the Container Engine
page and look at our cluster--
I created this cluster earlier.
Similar to App Engine
Flex, it's built on VM.
So it takes some time to start.
Not too long.
Just a few minutes.
We then created a
Kubernetes deployment
on that cluster
that has three pods.
And I initially
pre-configured it
to be serving the 5.7
version of our app.
I can go over here,
just reload it,
and you can see
that there's v5.7.
So what we'll do is
deploy version 5.8,
which we just pushed to GCR.
That's a relatively easy
thing to do in Kubernetes.
You can just go
and edit your spec.
So let me just zoom
in here a little bit.
You see the image that's being
used by the pod is demo app
v5.7.
All I need to do is
just change it to 5.8,
save it, and then close.
OK.
And now my deployment
has been edited.
So at that point the
Kubernetes master
knows that the
deployment that it's got
doesn't match the spec anymore.
It's going to bring
down the pods,
bring up new pods
with the new version.
And in a few
moments, just as long
as it takes for a
Spring Boot to get
started you'll be able to
start surfing traffic again.
You can configure Kubernetes to
do rolling upgrades, as well,
so that you have no downtime
between swapping versions
that you see here.
That v5.8 is now running.
AMIR ROUZROKH: So
Patrick, you basically
did what we did in App
Engine, going from 5.7 to 5.8
just with all of our control.
So you know--
PATRICK FLYNN: It's a
more manual process.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Yep.
It's a more managed process.
PATRICK FLYNN: Right.
OK.
So the next thing that we're
going to be showing you
is, as I showed you
earlier, in the Docker image
we configured the
Cloud Debugger agent.
The debugger agent
is a necessary piece
of the Stackdriver debugger,
or the Google Cloud Debugger,
which is a really exciting
product that Google provides.
Amir.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Yes.
PATRICK FLYNN: Earlier--
sorry about that, Amir.
Amir, Earlier on asked
you guys how many of you
had actually had a hard
to debug production issue.
It's happened to me a few times.
And it happens especially
at scale, right?
When you have a large
cluster under a lot of load
a lot of bugs can
pop up, corner cases,
that you simply don't have the
logging in place to effectively
diagnose.
And you don't have
a lot of options
for debugging, because you can't
attach a debugger in production
for a couple of reasons.
You don't want to
actually block requests
coming into an instance.
And if you have
100,000 nodes you
don't know where that
bug is going to happen.
You can't connect
to all of them.
So the Cloud Debugger
is a piece of technology
that Google developed internally
for our purposes, which
solves this problem.
The way that it works is that
when you set a breakpoint
in the Cloud Debugger there's
a Cloud Debugger master that
monitors all the agents
running for a specific service
and notifies them
that they need to be
looking for this
particular break point.
The second any traffic
on any of the instances
actually hit that line
they'll notify the master.
And eventually you'll
be notified, as well.
They won't break execution.
They'll just capture
state in the stack frame
and store it in a database.
AMIR ROUZROKH: So
basically, I don't
have to worry about having
down times, and maintenance,
windows, and all that
sort of stuff anymore.
OK.
PATRICK FLYNN: That's right.
So let's actually go and
show what kind of bug
we want to diagnose.
Let's go back.
Here you go.
Something's not right.
And I don't know if you guys
can figure out what it is.
But the site is telling me that
my browser is Firefox, which
is a great browser, by the way.
But the browser that I'm
using is Google Chrome.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Looks
like Chrome to me.
Yeah.
PATRICK FLYNN: That's a bug.
AMIR ROUZROKH: That is a bug.
PATRICK FLYNN: So let's use the
Cloud Debugger to figure out
what's going on.
This is happening on
our Kubernetes cluster.
You can start the Cloud Debugger
just by finding it over here.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Before
you go there, Patrick,
can you show the code that's
actually making this happen?
PATRICK FLYNN: Yeah, sure.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Maybe we
could just eyeball it.
All right.
The fuser agent is Mozilla Fox.
PATRICK FLYNN: Yeah,
we're basically
serving the hello path.
We're getting the user agent.
Checking it's contents
for a specific string.
If we see it, we figure out
what browser type it is.
And it looks like it
makes sense, right?
Mozilla is Firefox.
Explorer's Explorer.
Chrome is Chrome.
Cool.
So I have a Google Cloud
Debug run configuration.
Since you're IntelliJ
users, you're
all familiar with the way that
debugging works in IntelliJ.
You have the run configuration.
You click the debug button.
This is the Kubernetes
version that I had.
I'm going to attach to it.
I have a old watch
point from earlier on.
Going to delete it.
Hold on a second.
Let's try that again.
OK.
So you're going to--
I was practicing this earlier
and I had some previous states.
AMIR ROUZROKH: No,
I was going, sort of
just kind of listen in line
52 where Firefox is displayed
to see what's happening.
PATRICK FLYNN: Yeah,
so we know that we're
seeing Firefox, which means that
line of code is being executed.
Let's find out what's going on.
We're going to set the snapshot.
When the check mark
appears that means
that the master has confirmation
that that's a valid line.
We're going to go
and trigger the bug.
We don't know where the load
balancer sent that request.
It went to any of
the three nodes
that we've got configured.
And if we go over here
we can see the state.
So if you look at
user-agent, guess what?
The user-agent of Chrome
reports itself as Mozilla.
This is something
that browsers do
because of legacy, all right?
But with the Cloud Debugger it
was really easy to figure out
what was going on.
AMIR ROUZROKH: So you basically
got a whole stack trace
whenever that part of
the code was touched,
and that's really good for--
PATRICK FLYNN: Yeah, I
want to just point out
that the debugger is very safe.
It doesn't slow
down the execution,
or it's a really trivial amount.
We use it at Google
in production.
It only captures
the first snapshot
and then it disables itself.
So you'll get one sample of
what you were looking for.
In the future we're probably
going to provide you
with more options.
But for now it's just one.
AMIR ROUZROKH: But Patrick,
like, this is really cool ,
but you know, sometimes I don't
know when the trigger happens,
because it could
be an edge case.
Do I just, you know, wait there?
Can you show us a better way?
PATRICK FLYNN: I can.
I can.
So let's stop listening.
And imagine a real
scenario where
this is happening, where this
sort of hard to reproduce bug
suddenly gets reported.
Most of the time you're not just
waiting in the version of code
that's executing in production.
You're doing some
feature development.
You've moved over to
version 9 and you've
added like some
random out, or hellos.
I'm really creative here.
And then somebody comes and
tells you, hey, guess what?
We're having this crazy
bug in production.
We have no idea what's going on.
AMIR ROUZROKH: And that's
for version 5.8, by the way,
so you've moved on from that.
PATRICK FLYNN: Right.
So we actually
capture source context
at build time and deploy
it with the application,
both in App Engine, and
we configured things such
that we do it for
Kubernetes as well.
Which means that when you
connect we've actually
identified that the
version of your code--
let me zoom in here--
is not the same as the version
that's running in production.
And whether you've
committed things or not,
or you have unstaged changes,
we'll take all your changes,
stash them, and put
you on the version
of the code that makes
sense for the service
that you're debugging.
So let's do that.
We're going to get
rid of this guy,
because like I said earlier,
it got caught already.
And we're going to create--
oops.
I didn't mean to go there.
Create the new break point.
But at this point
this bug is always
going to happen
with Chrome browser.
But for a bug that happens
once every blue moon
due to some race
condition, or whatever,
you're certainly not going
to stop here and leave
your IDE in this state,
waiting for it to happen.
So what you can do
is you can stop.
And instead of telling the
debugger to stop listening,
you can tell it to continue.
At that point we know
that you want to go back
to your old workflow.
We offer to check out the
branch that you were on,
and un-stash your changes.
So we'll go ahead and do that.
And if we go here we see that
we're back to version 5.9.
So now if this gets triggered--
going to come back here--
we notify you in the IDE
that your hard to reproduce
bug has happened and you can
continue your debug session.
And if you look at the
version of the code,
now it's back to v5.8.
Many times I have been
tearing my hair out
because I've attached my
debugger to a version of code
that is different from the one
that my editor is showing me.
It happens all the time.
And it can take forever to
figure out what's going on,
especially if you have lines
that kind of match, right?
In terms of, they are executing,
but they're not the lines
that you thought.
OK.
That's cool.
AMIR ROUZROKH: So Patrick,
this is all great.
You know, another one of the
scenarios that I can think of
is I have deployed my version
5.8 as you've shown over here,
but I forgot that I would
like to log a certain value,
or a certain field over time.
I've moved on many,
many versions.
And you know, it's going to
be quite the hassle for me
to go back and deploy a new
version due to changed code.
Maybe you can show us the way
that we can do this better?
PATRICK FLYNN: I'd be happy to.
This is a scenario
I'd like to call,
oops I forgot to write logging
statements in my application.
This is a scenario
that helps with bugs.
It also is a scenario
that helps with people
who might be using logging
to generate metrics
about their application.
Maybe piping their cloud
logs into big data, right?
Into like, BigQuery,
for instance.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Right.
PATRICK FLYNN: So
in this scenario
we're actually using the
same cloud debugger agent
to insert dynamically log
statements into your production
app without requiring
you to redeploy.
And now every time
that line gets executed
on anywhere in
your cluster you're
going to see it in your logs.
So we don't have integration
into the IDES for this feature,
yet.
But we're working on it.
You can use the Cloud
SDK G Cloud commands
to create these log points.
If you Take a look over
here-- let me zoom in.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Patrick, can
show the line item in the code
that you're trying to log?
PATRICK FLYNN: Yeah.
That's an excellent idea.
OK.
So let's see.
Line 37.
I forgot to mention
that we have some really
nice hand-crafted Java libraries
that are coming out in beta,
at the moment, for some of our
main Google Cloud Services,
like Datastore.
And I'm using that here.
You just important
in your POM XML,
and you can write to Datastore.
Datastore is a really
good idea for people
who expect to have
really large data, right?
App Engine Flex can help
you scale your computation.
But it can't help you
scale your database.
You need to use a scalable
database if you really
expect large scale,
and Datastore
is a database that scales
horizontally automatically
for you.
It's sort of like the
App Engine for databases.
So we have this system
output line here.
But Really what I wanted
to do is figure out
every time I saved a data
store I want to be notified
that save has occurred.
So at line 37 you see
that we're actually
just returning the greeting.
Let me hit the endpoint.
I can show it to you.
All right.
We're just generating
a time stamp,
saving it to the database,
reading it, showing it to you.
This is demo purposes only.
Not particularly useful.
Now, if we go to Cloud Logging--
so Cloud Logging
is a service not
tied to App Engine that
aggregates all your logs
for all your instances,
because copying
logs from individual
instances is a real pain.
So what we've done is we've
filtered by next demo, which
is a tag that I'm putting in
front of a logging statement
so that we don't get
all the noise from all
the instances at the same time.
All the non-related to
this logging statement.
So if I refresh this
and go back to logging
you see nothing is
being outputted.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Right, because
you never wrote anything there
to write.
PATRICK FLYNN: We don't
have a logging statement.
AMIR ROUZROKH:
Logging statement.
PATRICK FLYNN: So
now if you take
a look at this G4 command--
can you guys see that?
AMIR ROUZROKH: I
think it's fine.
PATRICK FLYNN: All right.
So what we're doing is we're
calling the debug sub-command
to create a logging statement
in the demo control of dot
Java at line 37.
The demo controller doesn't
have to be fully qualified
if there is no ambiguity.
If there is, fully
qualified the class.
We've preplanned the next
demo to the statement
and just actually used
a value from the context
where the logging
statement is in the string,
and specified the target,
which in this case
is demo app 5.8 running
on the Kubernetes cluster.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Patrick, I'm
just curious-- oh OK, cool.
Yeah, I was going to say--
PATRICK FLYNN: Go ahead.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Were we on
5.8 or 5.9 version in the--
PATRICK FLYNN: I
believe we're on 5.8.
AMIR ROUZROKH: OK.
We were?
OK.
Yeah, just curious.
PATRICK FLYNN: I can
double check for you.
There you go.
AMIR ROUZROKH: O, the
[INAUDIBLE] header, OK.
PATRICK FLYNN: So if
we go back to visit
and if the demo gods
will be kind to us
it should appear
here any second.
Come on.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Come on.
PATRICK FLYNN: Come on.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Going
through all the dif--
PATRICK FLYNN: I've got
a bad feeling about this.
AMIR ROUZROKH: You do?
PATRICK FLYNN: Things
have been going too well.
AMIR ROUZROKH: I have
a feeling you're-- oh.
PATRICK FLYNN: Oh!
AMIR ROUZROKH: It did appear.
There it is!
All right.
PATRICK FLYNN: Fantastic.
I mean, this works at scale.
There are people with
hundreds of thousands
of App Engine instances
using Cloud Logging
and our diagnostic services.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Yeah, I
imagine, because you may even
have code that's deployed
way before, right?
And you just don't
want to go and mess up
some running application.
And you want to
be able to just--
PATRICK FLYNN: No, really
what these features are about
is saving developer time.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Yes.
PATRICK FLYNN: Making
you more productive.
Making the time to
identifying a bug,
to fixing a bug as
short as possible.
AMIR ROUZROKH: Again.
Core business.
Spend time on core
business code.
Rather than all
these other stuff.
PATRICK FLYNN: All right.
That's it for the demo.
We can switch back
to the presentation.
AMIR ROUZROKH:
That's really great.
We've got about 10 minutes.
I'm going to just do
some concluding slides.
So you saw what happened, right?
We went from App Engine
to Container Engine.
And then we did some live
coding, live debugging,
and also live logging, without
having any downtime incurred
on our application.
And so as Patrick talked
about, I just want to say,
all these tools are opensource.
They're all available on GitHub.
And I'm going to give you guys
the link right towards the end
of the talk when this ends.
But we've got Eclipse,
and IntelliJ support.
Maven and Gradle.
There's a bit of
difference between
the IntelliJ and
Eclipse support, bu
we're working on that.
These tools are continuously
getting updated as time passes
by.
So you're going to get the
updates [INAUDIBLE] available.
And you guys are
going to be going
through the different
sessions and seeing
many, many different
services that we offer.
Everything from ML, and
Bigtable, and BigQuery,
and Spanner, and so forth.
All of these have
handwritten Java libraries
available to you
guys to use so you
don't have to do a lot
of boilerplate code
around authentication
and so forth.
So please go ahead
and use these.
I will give you guys a link to
this, as well, towards the end.
And I'm just going to
talk a minute about vendor
flexibility.
And because of what
we did under the hood
for both App Engine
Flexible, and also for GKE,
this was a container
based solution,
you really can
take this anywhere.
And by anywhere we mean truly
even outside of Google, right?
So yeah.
So you can go with Container
Engine, and Compute,
because those will do the job.
But you can also run
Kubernetes on a hybrid mode
where you can have
machines in on premise,
and machines in
cloud, and Kubernetes
could move the containers
between the two
infrastructures.
You can also go to the
other cloud providers.
And there are a few out there.
And you can just run it on
your local machine, as well.
Basically anywhere
that Docker runs.
So you're free to move
to other platforms.
And that concludes our talk.
This should be from
top to bottom the links
you would need.
The top link would
be your gateway
to everything Java
and Google Cloud.
The next one is
where you can find
all the handwritten libraries.
And then the four GitHub repos
that have the plugins in them.
We always, always welcome
issues, bugs, requests,
feature requests, comments,
PATRICK FLYNN: Absolutely.
Please go to those GitHub
repos and check them out.
If you want to contribute
we would love it.
If you have ideas we'd
love to hear them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]